state local governments have made
trillions of dollars of promises to
their employees that they will pay them
pensions when those employees retire and
they've budgeted for these using methods
that are basically flawed in essence
what state local governments do is they
assume that for every dollar they set
aside that that dollar is going to grow
at an 8% compound annualized return they
assume that every dollar they set aside
is going to double in nine years and
that leads to budgeting procedures that
that greatly understate the costs of of
providing pensions to public sector
employees what this means is that there
is really no state or local government
around the u.s. that has run a balanced
budget in a very long time if state and
local governments do not achieve the
returns that they're targeting taxpayers
will be asked to contribute more to the
to the state local governments into
pension systems in order to pay for the
retirements of public sector employees
that's already happening now and it's
creating a lot of tension between the
10% of the u.s. population that works
for a state or local government and the
90% that does not so essentially we have
a situation where 10% of the population
is owed four and a half trillion dollars
by another 90 percent of the population
that 10% of the population happens to be
employees of state local governments who
provide essential services to us on a
daily basis it's actually hard to
imagine a worse arrangement than
borrowing sums of money that we are
never going to be able to pay back from
people who provide essential services to
us every day
like teachers and policemen firemen
Public Safety officials and other public
employees
financial markets don't like uncertainty
and in fact this is one of the reasons
that I see the financial crisis that
state and local governments in the US
will experience in the next decade or so
as being very analogous to the crisis
that is being experienced in Europe
indeed even if you think about Greece
which is not a large country by by
European standards the uncertainty over
how that Greek debt was going to get
restructured through financial markets
into a lot of turmoil and in the u.s.
there's a great deal of uncertainty as
to how all of these unfunded debts are
going to get resolved because laws in
many states offer protections to these
public employee pensions and as a result
the states are not going to be able to
simply default on these pensions there's
going to be great a great deal of
competition between municipal bond
holders and the recipients of the of the
pensions as to who is going to get paid
first state and local government pension
funds are one of the main investors in
private equity and venture capital in
fact one could say that they are really
the lifeblood of private equity and
venture capital firms they provide
almost four hundred billion dollars of
current investments and commitments to
private equity venture capital and
related investments and a lot of these
funds are now looking to be cash flow
negative the amount of assets that they
have is decreasing as these pension
funds come under greater and greater
strains and right now you have two
things going on on the one hand they
have the incentive to maintain these
investments in somewhat riskier asset
classes in order to target expected
returns but on the other hand the amount
of assets under management is going down
and I think that for the private equity
and venture capital industries it's
going to be important to have a robust
source of financing that's going to
continue from public sector pension
funds and so the private equity and
venture capital industries will need to
be thinking about where the funding
sources for their investments are going
to be in five to ten years who are going
to be the main limited partners for
their investments in the next five to
ten years because the traditional
lifeblood of public sector pension funds
may or may not still be there on a
medium to long term horizon